televangelist Christian demagogue Pat
Robertson has passed away at the age of
93. the Associated Press reporting Pat
Robertson broadcaster who helped make
religion Central to Republican politics
dies at 93 a man we have covered for a
very very long time founder of the
Christian Broadcasting Network the 700
Club for more than half a century he was
known for his 700 Club television show
now as I said when Rush Limbaugh passed
away and as I said when we've seen the
deaths of many different figures I don't
wish death upon anyone these individuals
to the extent that they have family and
friends and loved ones they are loved
they are missed people are grieving and
that is their absolute right and
privilege and also I can recognize that
in their public life they were
extraordinarily damaging to the country
and to the world and Pat Robertson was
one of the most damaging religious
influences in America of the last 50
years part of the movement that stuffed
and stuffed and stuffed religiosity into
uh civil government and the Republican
Party wanted a Christian version of
sharia law this is the reality one
little highlight for you here is
um Pat Robertson at the uh in the
earlier phases of when the country was
going in the direction of saying Hey
listen like gay marriage not a big deal
etc
apocalyptically stating that it will
bring the Judgment of God on the nation
and we will be vomited out by the land
if uh the equality act passes let them
know that you are opposed to what is
called a
of course it's it's got a name and all
they always give the good names to these
things this is a devastating a blunt to
religious freedom and to the sanctity of
America if you want to bring the
Judgment of God on This Nation you just
keep this stuff up you know I was
reading in Leviticus where it said
because of these things the land will
vomit you out right vomit you out I
think God will say I've had it with
America if you do this kind of stuff I
want to get rid of you as a nation and
you know there's plenty of stuff that's
going on when you look at this so super
scary stuff you will get vomited out I
do want to remind everybody there is a
very long list of things that Pat
Robertson during his storied career said
are demonic or potentially demonic
remember that demons can attach
themselves this is from Pat Robertson I
can't play all of these clips but you
can find them in our archives secondhand
sweaters can have demonic attachment
Ouija yoga Harry Potter feng shui karate
horoscopes the Twilight series paintings
of Buddha TV shows about ghosts can be
demonic Halloween absolutely demonic
psychics can be demonic when young girls
levitate their friends at sleepovers
that can be demonic and sometimes
adopted children from other countries
can be demonic according to Pat
Robertson we also had this absolutely
classic classic moment where Pat
Robertson said even little babies just
out of the womb could conceivably be
demonic as well remember this amen all
right here's the caller Lisa from Fallen
Nevada
my question is regarding demon
possession possession can babies be
possessed and if so does the age of
accountability come into play for
salvation right
um I I you asked about things can babies
be possessed and if so does the age of
accountability come into play for
salvation well the age of accountability
has to do at the point you know what
we're right from wrong and that normally
doesn't take a place to your old enough
to understand something's wrong so the
age of accountability can be five it can
be six it can be four it could be three
but uh can a baby be demon possessed I I
just believe if if
that child is born to a family of devil
worshipers there's a real possibility
that the the the the devil will think
that he has a claim over that child I
mean it's horrible to contemplate but we
you know I don't think that there he
doesn't take pleasure in giving us this
news but yeah babies can come out of the
womb demon possessed so 93 year old Pat
Robertson passing away
uh an incredible Legacy which I think is
a negative one
uh and we will leave it there we will
take a quick break and be back right
after this
I often have a much longer list of
non-fiction books that I'd like to read
than I actually have the time for and
that's when summaries of books can be
really useful our sponsor short form is
the platform that goes Way Beyond what
other book summary platforms do because
short form provides a clear and concise
overview of the book that you can read
or listen to in one sitting but you also
get a ton of other crucial context about
how the book fits into the broader topic
like for example I went through the
short form guide for an American
sickness it's a book by Elizabeth
Rosenthal about the financial incentives
that plague the U.S health care System
many of which we've talked about short
form perfectly sums up the book's key
points but then it goes further it looks
at the background on how rosenthal's
perspective fits into the larger debate
on American Health Care and this just
gives you a more complete and balanced
understanding of the book and that's
what I love about short form short form
has every non-fiction genre imaginable
and they publish new book guides every
single week my audience can try short
form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription if you'd like at Short
form.com Pacman the link is down below